method 1 cases and you don't muck around
with the algebra method 2 cases but you
do this which turns into a quadratic why
I wish you never have to muck around
with 3 cases just a - ok ok
method number 3 I'm going to wrap it ok
so how do you go about this well you
just think about what's the function ok
so if I consider on this what's it going
to look like ok so the first thing I'll
do is I'll consider without the absolute
values this is a super easy thing to
wrap ok think about it it has a vertical
asymptote where 0 0 it has a horizontal
asymptote where 3 because as you chuck
in big numbers you get 3 million over a
million so you're going towards 3 so ok
now what does this thing do in between
well you've got this guy over here this
guy here
what's the intercept where does it clean
does it come from just comes from the
numerator right so it's just my third
okay now that I've drawn this guy I
think about what happens when I start
the absolute value signs no ok now just
like before where it goes where it
changes right the point at which it
changes is 1/3 right that's where you
change over from one version to another
ok now the version that I've got right
now with a you know
which version was that that's the
version with X is greater than the cell
does that make sense so that part I
leave this part is corrected but the
rest of it should have a minus sign on
it right everything else should get
flipped upside down okay
so firstly this part lips it goes okay
and this guy flips so he gets a new
asymptote down the bottom view which
turns out it doesn't matter where it is
okay but if you're curious now what's
the question okay so I should what's the
question I want to be less than two okay
so where is 2
he is 3 so 2 is just believer lower
right okay so now that you can see the
parts that work right let's get one more
color just think of it okay this whole
branch over here right the one that I
flipped upside down that's all fine it's
less than zero right so it must be less
than 2 the other part that I want let's
make it a little Christmas Eve it's this
part in here how do you find that part
he just saw simultaneously right so
let's see when you saw this branch you
get if it's the same values right you
solve this one you get one so which
parts do I want I want less than zero
because this branch over here R is less
than a third so if it's less than a
third a different wall takes over for
the absolute ohm which we've been
noticing in these cases with a wall
right if less than a third then I put a
minus sign on it a whole lot so the
question is is this part less than x
equals 1/3 yeah because X is less than
zero must be less than 1 whichever
method you use okay make sure it's Daraa
make sure you end up you bring all your
answers together and you have a nicely
conclusion tie it up in a bow at the end
so that you know the marker
doesn't have to deep through whatever
cases you put together or an awful graph
and simultaneous equations in order to
get there there's your solution okay